[Music]
Pokemon let's go Pikachu and let's go
Eevee are gorgeous albeit lean
reimagining of one of the series most
beloved adventures while some features
fans have come to expect are missing
like abilities breeding and held items
let's go has an admirable amount of
depth for a game aimed at a younger
audience both games may not have the
same lasting appeal as previous entries
but revisiting Kanto and catching some
of the series most iconic creatures make
the journey worthwhile Pokemon let's go
Pikachu and let's go Eevee take you back
to Kanto the home of pokemon red blue
and yellow not much has changed
structurally but the previously 8-bit
region has been realized in vibrant
detail revisiting some of the series
most memorable locations like Viridian
Forest and celadon City on a big screen
is an absolute joy areas that were once
composed of lines and simple shapes are
now colorful forests and detailed cities
Pokemon both big and small roamed the
wilds giving personality to the region
well let's go streamline some of the
more vague parts from the originals like
bringing water to the saffron city
guards the layout of the region and your
progression through it is nearly
identical
fortunately let's go shed some of red
blue and yellow s'more archaic designs
for example hms hidden moves that
allowed you to get past certain
obstacles are replaced with secret
techniques that fulfill the same purpose
but don't take up any move slots like in
recent Pokemon games this means you can
focus on team composition and
complementary movesets instead of
figuring out how to divvy up hms between
your party pokemon one of let's goes
most fundamental changes is how you
catch pokemon instead of random
encounters and wild Pokemon battles of
previous mainline games let's go adopts
Pokemon goes catching mechanics
[Music]
but one roamed the wilds in real-time
and you have to walk into one to
initiate catching it
let's go encourages you to catch pokemon
more so than any other mainline Pokemon
game and it's better for it sure
catching every single species has always
been the overarching goal but I've never
felt more inclined to complete my
pokedex you don't need to worry about
accidentally defeating and therefore
failing to catch a rare or one-time
Pokemon and if there's a Pokemon you
don't want to catch you simply avoid it
yes that means you can even avoid zubats
catching Pokemon is also the most
efficient way to level up this
alleviates the need to spend significant
amounts of time grinding and makes it
easier to experiment with different
party compositions
[Music]
let's go also introduces catch combos
which occur when you catch the same
species of Pokemon multiple times in a
row as you build your combo your chances
of running into a rare and powerful
Pokemon increase it's great knowing that
luck is not the only factor involved
when trying to catch a rare Pokemon and
it's very hard to stop when you're deep
in a combo knowing something good might
spawn however the new catching mechanics
don't come without issues the joy kahn
motion controls are inaccurate at best
and unpredictable at worst over the
course of my journey i never found a
reliable way to throw a Pokeball to the
right or left in most cases I would just
wait for the wild Pokemon to return to
the center of the screen before throwing
a pokeball and even then the ball
wouldn't always go where I wanted it to
the pokeball plus controller and
optional poker ball shaped accessory is
a bit more precise but because there are
only two physical buttons on the
controller navigating menus and
interacting with the world can be a pain
as novel as it is to seek antowain a TV
handheld mode is the best way to catch
wild Pokemon you can either use the
switches gyroscope sensor or the left
control stick to line up a throw and
it's much more accurate despite changes
that make the Pokemon experience more
accessible than ever let's go is
surprisingly deep it does an excellent
job at easing new players into some of
the more complex mechanics without being
bogged down by tutorials each Pokemon
still has 6 base stats and one of 25
nature's and the game seamlessly
presents all that information to you
unfortunately those invested in the
competitive side won't have as much to
sink their teeth into the absence of
abilities held items imbrie
limits the potential for highly
competitive play you can farm for
Pokemon with higher stats but even if
you do manage to catch a Pokemon with
the stats you want you won't have much
to do with it if you do decide to build
a competitive team the online features
are limited you can tray it in battle
and that's about it there are no ranked
battles the global trade system is
non-existent and there is no wonder
trading the bare-bones trading features
may be disappointing at first but given
the smaller roster of Pokemon I never
felt that I needed the GTS or Wonder
trade to complete the pokédex
[Music]
however the inability to matchmake in
battle with other trainers online is a
bit of a letdown despite these
concessions Pokemon let's go Pikachu and
let's go Eevee are delightful
reimagining 's of the series origins and
a deep RPG in their own right it makes a
lot of smart improvements on the
original red blue and yellow while
holding on to what made them so special
in the first place
fans of the series might be let down by
the lack of features they've come to
expect but pokemon let's go pikachu and
let's go Eevee take the Pokemon formula
in some exciting new directions
[Music]
you